hello everyone how has doing hope you
guys are having a wonderful day they
were here with another video and today's
video is going to be a merging video so
it's been a while since I've done one of
these and I honestly haven't done a
whole lot of merging in the last few
months since I started my hardcore
Ironman but it's something I want to get
back into so today what we're gonna go
ahead and do is I've done this before
where I start with 1 GP and try to work
out what I think I'm gonna do in this
video is go to free-to-play grab 1 GP
from someone and I'm gonna turn that 1
GP into hopefully about 5 mil over the
span of little less than a week and
hopefully in that time I'll be able to
go back and trade the person 5 mil and
they could buy them self membership and
do whatever they please with it so with
that said let's go ahead and hop on over
a world one's cancer so I think I'm
gonna go to probably a smaller world
yeah let's just go ahead go to America
is it is it appropriate of me to go to
American World or should I go somewhere
else because I'm not American alright
fine I'll go to UK alright well as most
beggars do you gonna go ahead and stand
at the GE and then we'll start spamming
off alright I think that's a good
message you need one GP you won't regret
it this is gonna be flawless someone's
gonna give us some money it's probably a
giveaway that I'm on a high-level
account but who knows alright so one
Walker the students level six okay the
problem is with this if he gives me one
GP I don't know if a level six is gonna
be playing in a week's time
a hundred and one GP oh alright alright
this dude's got it thanks man all I
needed was one but we can start off with
101 all right um I gotta add this guy
real quick he's not he's not adding me
come on oh my friends list is full god
sorry um someone's gotta go all right
let's get this guy's backstory we need a
little bit of info before I can take
this man's money
alright well ask him if he's new I think
that's appropriate alright alright so
the students buying members tomorrow he
just came back after playing for a while
this is like perfect so he's gonna be
play which is really nice and on top of
that he's gonna be a member so he's
gonna need some cash to start out
hopefully I can do this guy in with a
little bit of a treat alright so this
would be the only plug of the videos who
do not figure I don't plan on talking
about them much more than I used to but
if you guys are wondering what site I'm
using to find the margins I'll be using
for this video I use GE tracker there's
a link to their site in the description
down below they have a lot of cool
features some payable some not if you
guys want to go ahead and check them out
feel free but that's the service that
I'll be using for this video what
that said let's go ahead and start off
with the 101 Jeep alright so right now
apparently from the prices I'm saying
granite 500 is apparently worth about
yet as you guys can see actively traded
price 3.5 K I have a hundred won GP so
I'll just put it in the hole 101 on this
I think that's probably gonna be the
best way to go about it hopefully we can
buy that and then sell it off for a 3k
profit it seems like we can do this
maybe even within the hour so hopefully
so now in regards to what we can sell
this for hopefully I mean I don't want
to be greedy I'll go 3200 you know I'll
accept that that's perfectly fine for my
contribution so it probably only took
about 10 minutes to buy so hopefully it
takes a little less time to sell you
know maybe there we go left for about an
hour and a half but we were able to get
it so while I was gone so we easily
turned a hundred GP into 3200 so it
obviously makes sense at this point to
go ahead and just reinvest and say you
know five or so and see what we can do
on top of what we have now now something
a little obscure is kept it Clause not
really to experience on these myself but
apparently you can buy them for around
six hundred and sell them for upwards of
thirteen K now I'm not really gonna you
know anticipate the 13 K necessarily but
this would be something to put some of
our money into for the time being now I
guess it's time to go ahead and wait and
see what we can do with them so
basically what I've done now is I went
ahead and bought four Granite's at 500g
and basically I have three left I did
sell one for a total of three point two
k and from there I went ahead and bought
five of these teleports now these
teleports aren't often bought and sold
so I can trade them for 2.3 K which is
more near their actual price and
basically this will allow me to turn 2.5
k investment into a little over 11 K so
definitely not bad at all and working
our way up hopefully we can get these to
sell there we go would you look at that
we were able to sell off all three the
granite for 700 GP each 600 GP profit on
each and then all of the teleports for a
really good margin 1.8 K on each take
out this money though up to 17 K already
turn 101 into 17 pretty easily now gonna
go ahead and I think we'll be able to
find something pretty decent with 17 K
alright so it's later at night I'm about
to go to bed but I did end up buying
some gothics pages as you guys can see
for 2.8 K each so I went and sold those
for a 2.6 k profit per one now that did
make us a little over 5 K and right now
we have 11 cake
to guthix pages to sell which hopefully
we'll be able to sell for a little over
10k and then some gray hats which are
really mad I'm not all too confident
about them basically I bought them for
around 1k and earlier they were selling
for a lot now obviously not as much so
930 that's like great we're just gonna
try to put them in for at least a little
bit of a profit at one point 9k here we
go it is the next morning so was not
able to sell off any of the gray hats so
looks like we could be stuck for him
with them for a little bit
one thing I did do though I did end up
buying the maple black Jack's and sold
off the rest of the gothics pages so now
up to 12 K the hats and the maple black
Jack's now these should be able to sell
somewhere near 5k so 5.30 I'm gonna put
them in for will hope for the best now
with the gray hats
I'm guessing it's going to be just best
to see what they buy for however I don't
have a whole lot of confidence yes so
looks like we're gonna lose you know
maybe 50 GP per one that's not bad I'm
just gonna get my money back out of
these because there's really no point
having them I had a lot of classes today
but 15.9 km/h axe obviously a good merge
their turn 9k into 16 and all the gray
hats are sold so in total up to 33 k now
alright I want to do a little bit of
homework so back in about an hour and a
half and yeah no hair talismans no muddy
keys have sold really not surprised by
the air talismans those are gonna be a
long shot hopefully in the future the
money keys I lower a little bit to 4k
but these Bandos crow's ears I'm not
exactly sure how you say that apparently
I can sell them for about nine K each so
yeah we're definitely gonna try to do
that 9200 and that would be 30 K that
I'd be pretty happy to pretty much after
I stopped recording that clip
surprisingly enough we sold two on I
didn't really think that was going to be
a thing and here we go so yeah okay I
just needed to store my 55 GPU hoping
for a long shot but granite shields
right now apparently have a 20k margin
and they buy in so relatively quickly I
was planning on going to bed but I mean
this is a pretty good merchant if I can
sell this off pretty quickly I may stay
up in time to actually be able to merge
a couple of these and maybe we can reach
100k off of them and here we go next
morning so yeah I I was tired I fell
asleep I can merge it
or I wait I waited like 20 minutes it
didn't sell but now it has sold so grand
shield off 454 K on top of that pink
elegant four nine at this point I'm
really just gonna have to buy an air
towels but obviously these aren't going
to sell as is even at that price I mean
80 I guess we're making a little bit of
money off of each of these not really a
whole ton I'm not all too worried about
them at this point really they were just
kind of a longshot thing that was kind
of hoping for and here we are another
grand than shield sold off so as you
guys can see I did do a merch a little
bit ago where I was able to make a
little and now we definitely just made
13 K I believe yeah 13 off of that so up
to 86 K in total now I can buy two of
these shields which will really allow me
to start you know flowing in the money I
don't even know what just happened I was
able to buy one granite shield for about
34 yea 37.4 and somehow I sold one 470 K
now I don't know how I thought I had the
offer in just sitting there waiting to
sell for 50 K and somehow it sold for 70
I'm not entirely sure but I'm definitely
happy to take the coins and there we are
got three grand and shield to sell off I
did actually have another merch in here
somewhere
after that 70 K one oh that one was
really nice but the margins went down so
back down to 47 K but we are now up to a
hundred and sixty while I wouldn't
normally probably switch up the item
that I'm going for at the moment granite
shields are providing a 10k margin and I
can't turn down an easy 40 K if they're
buying and selling this quake there we
go did I did a lot of it did a lot of
flips of these so basically I was able
to sell off to as you guys can see and I
was able to buy another two I think
there was another merch in there
somewhere but oh man we are killing it
with these merchants right now what yes
so see I am about to make 13 K profit
off of all these which is definitely
really nice and yeah we'll sell those on
for 98 K that'll bring us up to 210
total gonna go ahead and merch a couple
more of them alright so I left for a
little bit I tried to do some merchants
as you guys can see I mean these dens
were kind of just a throwaway merch I
didn't really think anything would come
of it but obviously made a staggering
600 GP on top of that I sold off all of
the granite shields and now in total we
are up to 220 K
few warrior rinks coming in at 71 case
should be able to sell them for about 80
so nice little bit of profit there
obviously ATK another thing I'm gonna go
ahead and do an ancient page one
apparently I can buy these for about a
hundred ATK and the sell price is about
250 so if we're able to buy one of these
and sell it off relatively quickly it'll
be a decent merge and there we go got
the ancient page to sell so that is a 62
K profit they're definitely happy with
that and now going to go ahead check out
the mind shields we got him for 19 K a
pop and should be able to sell them for
thirty four K per one so I was able to
merge all of the mind shields however
now we're kind of at a standstill we got
nothing really going on but we do have a
lot of cash now so up to 353 K kind of
hard to keep up at this point one thing
that I have to work on with this video
is the fact that all these 10k merges
while they are fun and exciting it's
it's hard to keep track of all of them
because the video can only be so long so
before I go any longer basically flipped
for Carol skirts the first two were for
11 K profits of 22 K bears and then for
K per one here overall you know 30 K
made there now once we go up I was able
to make 23 K per saradomin d hide that
I've been doing lately so in all we are
up to 430 K gonna go ahead and start
buying more of these because that is
some nice profit they buy in so pretty
quick here we go treasonous rings have
actually been pretty decent for me as
you guys can see I was just sold one for
645 K before this though I did merge
some purple sweets for a little bit just
to be able to get enough cash for the
trees in spring at the time well I mean
I guess I had enough but I was able to
merge it for 45 K the first time and
then the second time I was actually able
to merge it for 90 K so we are up to 730
and there we go we did a lot of Sarah
diamond sword merges but they were
definitely really good so as you guys
can see I started off with AE about a
50k margin and then it went down a
little bit I had to start selling for
you know a little under 40k but
definitely happy with it I did 7 merges
so I made a little bit over 200k
probably closer to 50 and in total we
are now close to 1 mil and this would
seem to be where the entire video takes
a turn look at this what the hell so uh
yeah I came back from class I decided to
go on and look at some margins real
quick and I found that corals leather
skirts had a pretty good one so I was
able to sell one
for a hundred and fifteen K profit as
you guys can see there and then I
lowered the price by one thousand just
to make sure that that person was
undercutting me that bought that
undercut and over cut and it's a really
kind of annoying thing about merging but
you know I'm just making sure and I sold
off another two so I've made three
hundred and sixty K so far and you know
maybe five minutes these things buy and
sell relatively quickly and I have
another for after this that I can
hopefully buy and sell but up but right
now as far as total cash we're over 1.4
mil so killing it a little while later
here we are with some dragon chain
merges so yeah I did end up buying
another five Carol's leather skirts but
I was in labeling her cheese for 25k the
margin went down pretty quick as you
would assume so in total I ended up
making you know 125k in that merch which
is still nice and then from there I went
ahead to merge four dragon chains for
50k per one so that was a 200k profit
and now we are up to 1.7 milk here we
are a little while later went ahead and
merge some holy sandals tried finding
some margins I obviously merge some I
guess not obvious I guess I haven't
checked it with it yet Murchison
barracks skirts though I made you know
40k on each one I ended up merged in
three in total so 120k profit but yeah
ended up buying these holy sandals for
four six six KH and which means I went
ahead and made 40k and each 120km
and here we are so the grotesque
guardians just came out so I don't have
it in my history anymore because a lot
of stuff had to happen on this account
but I did end up buying a pair of
armadillo boots
both for 800 and around 850 to caper one
now I was able to sell one overnight for
1.4 mil I saw the margin before I went
to bed and I was hoping maybe I'd be
able to jump in on it and obviously I
took full advantage of that so gonna go
ahead and sell off these for hopefully
910 K maybe I mean they couldn't to sell
yet 912 that's fine with me up to 2.7
Melba definitely really nice so I did
get a hundred K merch on this blowpipe
and then another hundred k here then I
went ahead and checked the tour eggs
margin because I wasn't really entirely
sure what it was and it was a hundred
and three K so I lost 103 K there so in
total up a hundred K still and then yeah
going forward that's all just stuff I'm
buying for The Gargoyle boss but I ended
up buying for for 270 this one was
checked to see what the price could sell
was cuz obviously it dropped and so in
total off of these four
where I ended up selling them for a 240k
profit so all in all about 340 K profit
and we're up to a little over 3 mil down
and here we go so I do have a lot of
malediction shards and this isn't as I
guess it's it's very close to a merge
basically it took me all night to buy
these typically they're by pretty slow
I'm gonna go the wilderness and put them
together and sell them off as shields
and show you guys how much I make but
before that I do want to say that I did
make a little bit of money off of two
tanzanite fangs basically with tanzanite
fangs they are pretty much blowpipes
all's you have to do is use a chisel on
them and then they become a blowpipe and
I was making 200k per one yesterday so I
ended up making 400 K before I went to
bed and then they weren't going anymore
so I switched it up and went for
malediction shards so I ended up buying
- as you guys can see for about one
point five seven six caper one so yeah
we should be able to sell them for about
1.8 militate profit per one and we are
definitely looking good as far as the 5
mil also got another 300 6 K right here
that got stored and there we go so
didn't manage to sell off the
malediction wards for a total of 3.5 ml
I ended up spending a little over 3.15
so I guess in total it's about three
hundred and close to 50k profit so
definitely happy with that in total now
up to three point eight mill we are
closing in one of the problems that I've
seen and I'm probably just gonna have to
give away the money to some free-to-play
player because this guy has not logged
on and he just I asked him if he was
gonna be on he said he would he lied and
here we are so I have one more grant a
hammer to sell for 948 K but I did go
ahead and profit off a three of them
almost 100k per once that's obviously
300k profit if I sell this one that's
400 but right now I'm gonna go ahead and
try to buy yeah three more yeah yes yeah
three more why not I mean if I'm making
100k H that's way too easy and these
things buy and sell pretty quick and
they haven't dropped a whole lot so I'm
pretty happy managed to sell off another
set of grano hammers so as you guys can
see I bought another three and I was
able to sell two of them for a hundred K
profit and the other one for 25k profit
so in total off all the granite hammers
I think at this point I've made probably
about 650 K maybe a little bit more a
little bit less but up to 4.4 ml we are
closing in and I can't do any more
hammers to the thing I hit my limit
this could be it I did do a little bit
of merges a layer as you guys can see
these toxic blow pipes I made 100k on
two merges of just the blowpipe itself
and then I ended up making 120k on this
one to changing the tanzanite bank to a
blowpipe and then another 100k right
here on top of that made barely any
money at all on these rings of recoil
but I did make 70 K on each one of these
granite hammers giving me a 200k profit
there as well now collecting I think
that oh you're so close okay 13 K away
and here we are five mil I ended up
merging another 14k is over skills for
one JP merch on each one pretty quick
stuff and yeah over five mil now so I'm
gonna go ahead and give it away at this
point
he hasn't logged on at all I told people
my claims yet to even add him and he
hasn't come back I guess that's a
problem that comes with giving or I
guess kind of promising a level six some
money but I'm gonna go to free-to-play
we're gonna find someone that looks like
they need a little bit of money and yeah
we'll make someone's day so we did we
did finally get a trade I'm not exactly
sure how to say this guy's name Ardwick
jr. I asked for 5k this man gives me ten
what a baller
alright 10k in a free-to-play world I
appreciate that man alright get back
here let me let me give you this come on
come on in buddy alright hopefully
enjoys it there you go man Oh 1gp turned
into five male hopefully this guy has a
good time with it
I appreciate that man oh yeah there we
go alright so I have my public con
thanks thanks man
alright there we go so hopefully enjoys
it yeah that's definitely gonna help him
out a lot I mean granted he has some
gold Jean he's looking pretty fly right
now but I think that five mil can help
them out so enjoy that man and yeah so
that'll be it for this video hopefully
you guys enjoy if you guys do make sure
to leave like if you guys want to see
more merging videos like this from me
make sure to let me know in the comments
down below and if you enjoy my content
make sure to subscribe for future videos
but with that said hopefully you guys
have a wonderful day and peace